good morning everybody thank you for
coming first of all let me say how
grateful I am the Simon's Institute for
hosting this event and this entire
program I'm having a great time here I'm
sure I'm sure I'm not the only one and
also thanks for the organizers of this
workshop to promote anything to speak I
will tell you about functional
programming over sets of opposites with
atoms this talk is related to some talks
that you've already seen and this
workshop on Monday Michael I told you
about sets with atoms and that talk
could also be titled imperative
programming oversights with atoms so I
will now do the same routine essentially
but for functional programming yesterday
your honor and I'm going to build on
other theory that McCoy presented
yesterday Jana spoke about first thought
refundable CSPs which were essentially
sees these over sets with atoms and I
will also use some some examples and
very superficially I will use some
examples and some results that she
presented and also MJ on Monday if I
remember correctly gave a presentation
where he didn't mention sets with atoms
explicitly but what he talked about is I
think a rich source of examples of or
applications of what I'm going to
present today so this is also related
this sorry so might hasn't spoken yet so
I this is this is the the past talks but
today today afternoon the Tama will also
speak about about orbit finite sets this
talk will be a bit unusual for this
workshop in that I will not show you any
theoretical results whatsoever that's
because all the theory that I will need
has been already covered by by McCoy and
your honor instead I will give you a
rather practical engineering oriented
talk aiming to show you how that theory
could be put to work so let's do some
programming
over sets without Adams first so if
let's say we want to do some programming
with finite sets and I will I'm going to
use Haskell syntax because what I've got
what I'm going to say is it's a
modification of Haskell so let's say I
define in Haskell I define a new type
constructor set that's given any type
given any type any constructs a new type
set a which is implemented just as as a
type of finite list let's say now this
tech that I've only barely started but
I'm already cheating you this is not the
way at all how how sets are implemented
in Haskell it's a lot more complicated
than in the actual library they are
implemented by balance trees for greater
efficiency but let's say I'm going to do
this just for the purpose of
illustration so you have every right to
be lost so this is just the type of
lists of elements of type thing this is
a standard Haskell construction ordered
lists yes sequences of elements yes
yes in half scales it sits there can
even be infinite but I should be
infinite but let's forget about that
let's say are only interested in finite
sets here and then I can implement some
primitives for example I have I can have
a constant empty that returns the empty
set
it is probably implemented as the empty
list
that's a polymorphic constant in the in
that for every type a there is a
constant like that I can also define
some functions like answers such as the
insert that takes an argument of type a
an argument of type set a and returns
another set and just inserts there adds
the element to a set then there is a
very important function map that given a
function from A to B and given an a set
of elements of a returns the set of
elements of type B by applying the
function
yeah and you can define many functions
that in fact in the standard library of
Haskell there is a plenty of there are
plenty of functions of this of this
general kind there are two largest and
inter definable and then of course you
might you might wonder what is the set
of primitives that you want to do to add
first and then perhaps you can implement
all the other functions of this kind
using just those primitives and not the
actual internal representation of and
then the definition of the of the type
constructor set but yeah so in the
actual library I think most of them are
actually primitives because efficiency
is very important and then using this
these these these this say primitive
functions on sets you can write your own
programs so let's say I want to call I
want to solve the problem of computing a
transitive closure of a relation where a
relation is now implemented as as as an
element of the type set of a a meaning
the set of pairs where the first
component of each pair is of type a and
the second component is of type a as
well so let's say I want to come I want
to compute the transitive closure so
first I might begin by defining a
function of this type this is a point
mode function that for each types for
each for each three times a B and C
compute the the composition of two
relations
I won't define it here unless you want
me to it is a liner and then using this
funk it's a rather boring thing this is
perhaps slightly more interesting using
now this function that computes the
composition of two relations I can
compute I can compute transitive closure
of a relation this is our of this type
giving an endo relation say of Taiwan
type a I can compute its transitive
closure by by saying this so let's say I
I'm getting a relation ah I first
compose it with itself I get a new
temporary relation r1 if this is already
a subset of I it is a SUP relation and I
I returned it the declaration is already
translated thank you very much
otherwise I added to one the to our own
computer transitive closure it's a
recursive function so this is this is
not the transitive and reflexive closure
this is just a transitive closure before
if you want to compute the transitive
closure this gets slightly slightly
different and then if you if I if I say
write down the relation of this kind the
transitive closure where it returns this
other examples of this sort of are are
say graph to cholera bility if I want if
I have a graph that said that's a
relation of course I can write a
function that returns the boolean value
whether they're depending on not
depending on whether the graph is two
color ball or not and that's a very
similar program to what I shall be on
the last that is essentially a
reachability problem we look for cycles
about length there is such a cycle then
I return false otherwise are returned
through another example is draw 3
colorability which is a bit different of
course but then there is a standard
procedure of that we can we can just
that's a very naive approach to to solve
the choral ability where we don't have
very smart approaches but but but we can
just try to generate all partitions of
vertices into three sets and for each of
them check if it's a legal coloring so
that's that's obviously our explanation
time algorithm but but it's also not
very difficult to write down using the
previous iteration that I showed you so
this is how programming with finite sets
look like a finite finite structures
well let's move to sets with Adams
you've already seen this definition well
there's this notion a couple of times
this week so let's say we have some some
infinite set of atoms and you're invited
to think of them as not your numbers but
just with equality and then we can
construct sets like these so this is the
set of ordered pairs of distinct atoms
the set of two element sets of atoms
and for example such a relation so let's
let's look at this relation this is it
this is a relation a binary relation on
the set of atoms which is now
differently from the from these from
these two examples this is defined using
two parameters to our two concrete atoms
5 & 2 and well this is the definition
it's it's definable in the sense
explained by McCrory on Monday it's a
finite description of an infinite
relation and this is the sort of drawing
that explains how this relation looks
like the blue the blue portion is the
pairs of that are in the relation and
now that we have such a relation we can
for example to my might want to compute
its transitive closure so obviously this
positive structure exists and in
particular it's it's this one in this
case and if you it's I mean if you if
you ask a reasonably skilled programmer
to design data types for representing
such structures for such relations and
to write a program that computes a
transitive closure they would probably
not have very much difficulty with that
I mean of course you can transit compute
transitive closure symbolically and
there is a method for that and I'm sure
people do constraint programming they do
it all the time and then they might try
to write the program that that's this
now if you ask this we skilled
programmer to do that though the program
that they will write will probably be
quite different from the program itself
in stress regulation for the for the
finite list representation well because
they will probably work with formulas
explicitly so our goal here is to
provide a programming language so that
the programmer could write a program for
computing transitive closures for
example writing essentially the same
code as for finite sets working under
the intuition that under the intuition
of man directly manipulating infinite
sets without bothering about without
bothering
symbolic representation by formulas this
is another example that you've seen all
right well you saw that yesterday in
your honors talk this is the the we
would call it the satanic graph because
well this is the the it's an infinite
graph and this is the define a finite
portion of it it is not 3 colorable as
you as you as you as you saw yesterday
and you might want to ask whether such a
graph given as input is 3 colorable or
not and and then the question is how to
write programs how to program with this
how to program with these sort of
structures so this is what we do and we
wrote the Haskell library which is
called n lambda and that's exactly that
so what does it do first of all it
introduces a type Adam which is just
elements elements of this type are just
atoms just equality are there
there is also an equality function on
the data and then it it adds just as on
the on the on the first slide I showed
you it adds a type constructor set but
now this type constructor is supposed to
implement not finite sets but definable
sets over the type A
and then I can provide and this is what
is provided in the library a bunch of
primitives that are that are that allow
the program to operate all they said so
there is the empty constant there is
that a new a new thing is the constant
atoms which is the set of atoms and it
is an element of type of set atom so
it's a set of atoms that whether it's a
legal value of this type then there is
there are these primitives before in
certain maps um there is also an empty
function that is an important primitive
it lets you check if a set is empty it
doesn't return a boolean value returns a
new and you type with a child I will
explain in a moment so this formula type
is a new type that sort of replaces
boolean time that the boolean type it
needs to be a bit more complicated than
just two value set so how do you use
this let's say you open a session for
Haskell interpreter if you type Adams it
returns something like this so this is
this is how the set of atoms is
represented it's a set of a well the set
of a for every for every atom in the set
of atoms so in this in this output
represent in this output of the library
this this capital n represents
represents the set of atoms so this is
the value of the constant atoms let's
say I have this what does this function
do what I'm trying to do here is I want
to compute the set of all pairs of atoms
so what it does well what we says let's
say this is a function in the context
where an atom a is already fixed this
function for every atom returns the pair
of a B and then if I map this function
for atoms I get a set of pairs where the
first component is a then I map it to
every Aryan this this return some value
this is this is what the interpreter
shows you this is not exactly what we
want it's not a piece of atom this is
not a person of all atoms this is set of
sex
of pairs of atoms indexed first by Aegon
than what we did what we can do is we
can apply the sum function that given
the family of sets like the Union and we
and we get what we want okay so this is
the actual this is an actual session of
I don't I didn't do a demo I've recorded
the session just to avoid technical
glitches and I can do things like this
so for example let's take let's take the
set of pairs that we just that we just
calculated
I can I can now filter this set by a
predicate that says that these two atoms
are actually equal so this all happens
in finite time also so if I read so let
me let me stress the perhaps at this
point that if you know Haskell you may
think for a moment that our ability to
deal with infinite sets here is nothing
new in Haskell because car because
Haskell's had infinite lists to begin
with
but that's a very very different data
structure that we're dealing with here
so for example if you take so this set
of atoms is very different from for
example an infinite list that enumerates
all atoms if you if I now take a
membership function that says so this
this what what does this do this is a
function that takes an atom a and checks
if a is belongs to the set of atoms it's
supposed to return true for every atom
and now I can I can check that this
function actually turns true for every
different for every atoms now if I
interpreted the the set of atoms as an
infinite list this would loop this would
terminate but in our implementation is
actually that you terminates in the
entire committed runs to difference tree
so now that I didn't show you on the
previous slide what is the actual
implementation of the of the of the set
constant of the set type constructor but
from this from these outputs of of the
interpreter you can actually sort of
figure it out so let me let me come back
to that slide so now that this is a now
that I can tell you that a set of a that
where a value of type set a is a list of
saying well there is some there is some
value of type a qualified by a
first-order formula with some three
variables there
list of free variables bar is just name
of a variable so this is this is how
this works
so how this how this how this works is
internally in our in our library orbit
finite sets are represented by further
further the formulas and said the other
expressions represented as lists with
certain sequences of by of bound
variables and free variables and first
other formulas that qualify the
existence of some elements there is of
course as you probably may imagine there
are plenty of technicalities that are
rather boring and I'm not going to show
you that's not quite as simple as I make
it sound for example we must do
something with the with the conditional
statement of husker if-then-else
because it might happen that if that if
we have a conditional statement
if a condition then returns something
else returned something else it might be
that the condition is a formula on atoms
that at this moment doesn't have a
determined logical value because it
depends on some atoms whether and we
don't know whether these atoms are for
example equal or not
therefore we must sort of delay the
evaluation of conditional expressions as
long as possible so for example this is
and and for this reason we cannot we we
have to add to our library as a separate
conditional statement which is now a
function called ite if-then-else which
is a replacement for the Haskell
standard I give the Nerds construction
money Haskell even as they are
unfortunately not a function it is a
bunch of keywords so we couldn't reuse
that so there is a function that says
well let's say I want this so in a
context where a B and C I are some atoms
where I do a there are some variables
and I don't know what they are I want to
evaluate this program if these guys are
equal then return the singleton of an
atom see otherwise we can
the set of all atoms this is well typed
because this is a set of atoms and this
is a set of topic atoms so that's fine
but now now what should we how should we
evaluate this well in fact this
evaluates to the following set it
returns it returns the set of the atom
c4 whenever a equals B and the set of
atoms
well the atom D for every D such that a
is different from me this is the actual
symbolic representation of the value
here as you can see I did not actually
evaluate the condition I just pushed it
back to the logical this is this is
necessary and for this reason we had to
replace the the conditional Haskell with
this or add another conditional to work
with with with with internal
representations and also this is this is
the reason why boolean type had to be
replaced by by the this more complex
formula type but let me stress that for
the programmer it does it is actually
quite transparent the programmer is
invited to think that this is the proper
if the news construction and this is an
actual boolean value that is interpreted
to some value for every one for example
to some boolean value for every pair of
values a and B and that's it so this is
the intuition that programmer should
this is a very convenient iteration now
every now and then of course our
implementation needs to actually
evaluate some formula and return through
our false because I mean the programmer
might write a program if this is if the
set is empty write this on the screen
otherwise write something else on the
screen and we actually need to do
something so whenever we want to say
that a set is empty we have a phone we
have a bunch of formulas we have a we
have a we have a new heaven we have an
internal representation of a set and we
essentially need to check every now and
then whether some first order formula
the over equality is satisfiable or not
so we don't do it ourselves we invoke an
external SMT solver for that so this
entire
implementation is is integrated with
with an SMT solver we used three from
Microsoft but so for example when you
say when you say well is the set of
atoms empty then what does what the what
the interview want what what the
interpreter does is well computes it
computes the set of atoms which is the
essentially says where the set of atoms
you add an atom to the set whenever the
formula to holds and then if you check
if if if you want to check if this set
is empty then the library tries to say
okay so it's the formula through
satisfiable and we ask the SMT solver we
add set three for that and surprisingly
is that three would probably say yeah
okay it is it is satisfiable thank you
very much so so we are should so we
returned that this this is false
actually it's not empty so this is how
this is how this works internally now
example let's say we want to compute
transitive closure of relations but now
this is inside the library so this is a
new the new with a new then you said
constructor and as you can see so this
is the code for some computing
transitive closures and you can see that
it is the same code but the only
difference is that we now replace this
if with with our our new if not if then
else that's what this minor it's
actually copy and paste of course so
this is a I think rather convenient for
the programmer because it's really it's
really let's the programmer let's the
programmer work under the intuition that
these are really infinite sets and we
are we can check things like whether
some infinite set is a subset of another
infinite set or we can compute the
unions of doing to infinite sets and we
are we know that this will terminate
every such primitive
similarly for graph to color reality we
can also copy the code there's another
example that will be published at
popularly that has been accepted to
purple 2017 the the classical unglue in
an algorithm for for automata learning
it's essentially written well it's not
really written it's copied and pasted
with minor changes and it suddenly
becomes an algorithm for learning for
the following a nominal ultimate our
register of the matter so this is
actually I don't know if I if I find it
more exciting or depressing that you can
get pop-up papers for free if you use
this sort of powerful ideas so this is a
paper with a matter with Matteo who is
there who did a lot of hard work making
it so that technicalities there as well
but essentially this is where this is
what what what happens it's also
essentially the same code for the
example of three Corral ability there is
also the program for finite sets that
computes 3 colorability and it starts
with generating all three partitions or
vertices wrong this doesn't work now now
we now we now we hit a problem this
cannot be done because well first of all
there is uncomfortably many of these
partitions so there is no way even to
collect them in a reasonable set later
on let alone an enumerator so this
doesn't work but still we can write the
program in an lambda for computing for
for checking 3 colorability using what
you are not told you about yesterday
using the fact that if a coloring of an
offer of a definable graph exists then
an equi variant one exists that colors
each orbit with respect to monotone by
actions of atoms with the same color so
we we can generate three partition of
orbits but this seems to be impossible
to bility to be written down using the
primitives that i've described in a
number there are more primitives that
i've hidden from you so far that do
things like this given a list of atoms a
finite list of atoms and an element of
some definable type does this support
the set of atoms meaning that does this
does does this only use the atoms in on
this list or for example if you have a
with Adams a I can define a new function
that we turned that partitions this set
into orbits in terms the set of sets and
that so these are parameters are added
to n lambda they are not difficult to
implement using the internal
representation but they doesn't seem to
be possible to be to be defined from the
basic set that's a very good question
thank you I forgot to mention so so far
this this n lambda thing this and lambda
library is implemented for two kinds of
atoms for equality atoms alpha totally
ordered atoms
it doesn't matter very much it it it it
matters so the difference is what kind
of formulas you can use to define to
define your to define your sets and then
what is the parameter that you invoke
the SMT solver with what is the theory
that you allow this and dissolver to use
so this there is a switch in the in the
library that says use these atoms or use
these atoms and then these functions
because we begin to work to be to do it
rather differently but it's a parameter
of the library that the structure of
atoms principle so for this to work for
this line to work in particular we need
to work with all the atoms otherwise
it's not true I mean you can seem to
write the program but it gives you the
wrong fat you're all wrong results okay
so this is this is an interesting
example I think this 3 colorability
because we can still solve it but it's
not easy so I would say that these
problems as far as we understand fall in
three categories the easy the hard and
the impossible so the easy ones
we're all right like transitive closure
to collar ability or the other or the
unglue algorithm fatimata learning where
you essentially copy the same code and
it solves from from the finite world and
it solves the same problem for the end
for the definable world there are
impossible things impossible things are
those that rely on enumeration of atoms
so for example there is no way to
produce a list of element of
for definable set and we don't expect it
to be possible there is also the
function fold left that is sort of it
really relies upon ordering on elements
of a set in enumerate centers in some
order and then compute some some value
this is also impossible and we will
fully expect that and then there's also
the heart 3 colorability which is
possible but there you need to break the
convenient programming you seem to be to
have to break the convenient programmers
intuition about about about looping over
infinite sets you need to use orbits and
so on so this is actually I think I
think we we got so carried away with
implementing this stuff and resolving
numerous engineering problems and trying
to achieve efficiency that we sort of
neglect the problem of understanding
what is hard and what does it even mean
to be hard so I think that I don't know
if there is any sort of type theoretic
perspective on descriptive complexity
essentially but perhaps there is a
condition that observing a connection
here that we do not understand at all at
this moment and we would like to so this
is a and open this is an open problem
for the lack of trying
actually so if you if you're interested
this is this this is just this is full
deported fully documented and according
to all haskell standards you can
download it from there experiment with
it ongoing work is - this is currently
haskell library what we plan to do and
what we're doing now is integrated with
haskell more closely by modifying the
hassle compiler actually so that you you
you can do away with this pesky ide and
you can actually work with with
if-then-else haskell and it also baked
make things faster also the what we call
i told you about is the same thing but
for c++ which should also be published
and then of course a theoretical problem
of understanding the hard crowd which i
think it's rather exciting but i have no
idea how to how to proceed there i think
it's is something but something
interesting might happen
thank you and if you work well you know
that it is reachable you want to know
how you don't know anything the number
of say I mean that's that's an that's an
interesting idea
thank you yes we haven't thought about
it but there might be some potential I
think the publisher is limited but it's
nonzero but yeah justice I mean there's
only so much you can calculate with will
slicing lists and there's probably trans
transpose to this and by the way
laziness of Haskell is the only reason
why this ite function works because in
an eager language you cannot have a
conditional implemented as a function
that's that's impossible in Haskell
happily happens that you can do
something like implement ordinal
arithmetic I mean you can think about
you know the order type like an order
type of a you know ordering on N squared
or something like this three sets of
that I'm so like you know given to
relations of a certain order type can
you computer relation whose order type
to the sound for example or the product
of this thing are you I'm not sure I
understand the question so are you
talking about considering different set
of atoms or computing on the Equality
atoms with
computing on the Equality of so you can
think about an ordering as just the
order type on a you know a cross a or
whatever and then so if you have two two
relations which are linear orders can
you compute a relation which is the
which has a better take the sum oh I see
well I'd have to think about that okay
thanks very much